[Music]
all right it is now day 352 of Robert
Moses witch-hunt still zero evidence of
any collusion no evidence of any
wrongdoing and yet the investigation
goes on and on and on and it got really
bad today a federal judge courageously
standing up to this totally out of
control witch hunt in what is the
biggest or single biggest beatdown I
have ever seen in my life by a judge
during a federal court hearing over
former Trump campaign chair Paul mana
Forte's years old conspiracy charges
goes back 13 years a US District Judge
his name is TS Ellis the third utterly
rebukes the entire Special Counsel
investigation and telling a member of
Muller's team quote you don't really
care about mr. mana fort you really care
about information mr. mana for can give
you to lead you to mr. Trump and an
impeachment or whatever and according to
a fox news producer that was in the
courtroom the judge went on to say you
want man afford to sing and George Ellis
also slamming the scope of Robert
Mullins investigation saying you know we
don't want anyone with unfettered power
and the judge even mocked the special
counsel saying quote we said this was
what the investigation was about but
we're not bound by it and we were lying
a federal judge just confirmed
everything we have been saying on the
show for month
there is nothing Muller will not do to
malign this president everyone around
him it's always been about Trump not any
of these other people during a speech
that President was giving at the NRA he
reacted to judge Ellis's stunning
reprimand and beat down of team Muller
take a look none of that information has
to do with information related to the
Russian government coordination and the
campaign of Donald Trump doesn't have
anything to do it's from years before
to do with the campaign the judges let
me tell you folks we're all fighting
battles but I love fighting these
battles it's a battle over the rule of
law equal justice under the law equal
application under law it says it's a
battle over the Constitution and
according to our producer inside the
courtroom judge Ellis also raised
important questions over why rod
Rosenstein has not recused himself from
this Russia investigation now this comes
after the Deputy Attorney General shot
down a request from members of the
freedom caucus to review the unredacted
memo that now details why the FBI's
investigation into collusion started in
the first place
by the way hand them over it's important
to note this memo which outlines the
scope of the Russia investigation it was
written in May 3 months before Muller
was appointed and this is just one more
example of obstruction of justice from
the Justice Department which is actively
preventing members of Congress from
conducting important investigations
their role coequal branches of
government over the Russia profiles
abuse and so much more
it's called checks and balances co-equal
branches and Rosenstein and the FBI and
the Justice Department they are not
impervious to the rule of law
and it's time for Rosenstein and others
to resign and for this witch-hunt to end
now the clear obstruction by Rod
Rosenstein and the off the rail scope
now of the Muller probe is just part of
what is now an incredibly flawed
destructive so-called Russia
investigation this week we have multiple
leaks revealed and what do we see dirty
aggressive tactics team Muller has in
store for the President himself
including a series of open-ended
questions designed as a perjury trap for
the President of the United States and
according to reports we also know that
Muller has been holding the threat of a
presidential subpoena over the White
House of course there are also serious
issues surrounding molars team a biased
anti Trump Democratic Obama Clinton DNC
donors and then ethical
questions of people like Andrew Weissman
oh he was there at Hillary celebration
on election night that never happened
New York Times calls Weissman's Mullins
pitbull his aggressive tactics led to
the wrongful conviction of multiple
individuals people lost their jobs at
Andersen accounting Merrill Lynch
executives oh they went to jail for a
year he lost nine out of the Supreme
Court overturned in the Fifth Circuit
Court of Appeals uh pending so many
people's lives and President Trump
addressed this very topic earlier today
take a look well the problem was sitting
at this you have a group of
investigators and they say that I am NOT
a target and I'm not a target but you
have a group of investigators that are
all Democrats in some cases they went to
the Hillary Clinton celebration that
turned out to be a funeral so you have
all these investigators there Democrats
in all fairness Bob Muller worked for
Obama for eight years the president has
been right is right and he clearly is a
target now until prosecutors like
Weissman and other big time biased big
Democratic donors are removed from the
so-called investigation the president
should never agree to any interview of
any kind as Mark Levin said late last
night the Constitution is on his side
meanwhile the mainstream media they are
sharpening their claws actively rooting
for a showdown between robert muller and
presidents from and cheering for any new
anti-trump revelation out of the special
counsel so-called russia probe now you
think the the biased press in this
country you think they'll focus at all
on what judge Ellis said today these
historic remarks what he said inordinate
in this particular case of course not
you know just as we saw all week to
destroy Trump media they're totally
obsessed like so many on the left with
the demise of this president D
legitimizing this president they're echo
chambers so out of control well watch
for yourself there's no shot clock
forgetting the truth in this case we
need to know the truth did he or didn't
he
let's let the hearts for what they do if
the Trump presidency is a house of cards
let it fall - we can argue about the
points of law and obstruction whatever
business misdeeds of which Trump might
be guilty what I want to know with the
majority of Americans again have a right
to know is whether he cheated to win by
having the Russians even at the margins
stack the deck it's not just the legal
component there's also a political piece
of this that comes into play if the
president does save decide to fight a
subpoena he may face political fallout
especially with the midterms just around
the corner nobody can be sure how this
would turn out but that doesn't seem
like there's much reason for the White
House to be optimistic that it would win
such a fight just pathetic now sadly the
media's obsession and their hysteria
over Trump Russia collusion which is no
evidence of his causing extreme tunnel
vision
we're resulting in multiple flawed
stories and the reporting of totally
fake news anonymous sources including
everything you see right there on the
side of your screen and what might be
even worse is the media's bias of
omission over 15 months the president he
has been building a track record of
economic and diplomatic achievement but
you wouldn't know it if you listened to
fake news CNN MSNBC the conspiracy TV
network the president pointed a lot of
this out earlier today take a look so we
have the best employment numbers we
virtually ever had and yet all we hear
about is this phony Russia witch-hunt
that's all we hear
and without a doubt President Trump has
achieved a lot in 15 months and also
breaking today what do we have an
unemployment rate that is now dipped to
three point nine percent the lowest rate
since 2002 that the historically low
unemployment rate for african-americans
has sperrit Hispanic Americans women in
the workplace lowest ever unemployment
rate in 14 states don't forget about the
successful tax cuts the important
regulation reform the expansion of
American energy we could be energy
independent now and the president is
seeing what huge progress on the world
stage the likes of which Barack Obama
could never dream of accomplishing peace
and the Korean Peninsula could be within
reach and with the help of the Israeli
Prime Minister Benjamin Netanyahu Iran
is now finally being held accountable
they do have a nuclear program the US
has regained our international backbone
with Trump's actions in Syria Russia is
getting economically squeezed over their
malign 'men of and their actions all
over the world the American people
elected this president to win on the
world stage and right here at home so
don't be fooled by the tactics of the
left there Russia collusion obsession
their blatant hatred for the president
and anybody that supports him and
everything he represents the president
in spite of all of this is succeeding
and even more good news is just around
the corner all right also finally
tonight we have a breaking news report
that we want to bring you according to
the now less redacted version of the
house Intel report into Russia collusion
well we now know that James Comey made a
shocking admission that he actually
testified that the FBI agents all quote
no physical indications of deception
from former national security adviser
Mike Flynn despite telling our own Bret
Baier something completely different
oh that's called a lie